let's go to Rey from North Carolina Ray
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
I was just asking uh someone who
analyzes uh news articles or watches
like rallies for Mega candidates or
Trump for example is that I noticed that
there has been a focus on on trans
individuals and sports yes but what I've
noticed is that people mainly focus on
um mail or disciplines rather than the
female sport disciplines and it kind of
boggles my mind that I think maybe it
could be it's an easier
tactic to go after
um
trans
females and women's disciplines
um so it kind of how does that entail is
it just an easier way for them to
tear apart this topic yeah so here's the
deal you're bringing up a good question
which is they love to talk about someone
born biologically male competing in
women's weightlifting as an example or
women's swimming and there's a very
specific reason for that this is
basically a contrived issue so you take
the entire think about these as
concentric circles right okay so you've
got the biggest circle is
every issue that's out there within that
you have issues affecting uh American
politics within that you have social
issues within that you have lgbtq within
that you have trans issues within that
you have uh transports
to make that interesting which again is
it's it's a such a niche issue if you
talk about hey you know what this person
who was born biologically female and uh
identifies now as a man they want to try
out for men's uh ice hockey
all right well who cares let him I mean
it's like it's not a compelling story
it's not interesting let them try out
and most people would say if they're if
they're strong enough and physically big
enough and whatever to make the team let
let them play in the ice hockey who
cares so even Within
trans Sports you have to pick
essentially women's sports in which
physical size and strength makes a
difference and only focus on those there
are states like in South Dakota where
there is not even a single instance of
this being an issue as Scott Galloway
told us last week and they want to pass
laws about it so you are exactly right
they are picking what they believe to be
the most titillating
based on the idea of this six foot five
individual born biologically male
weightlifting against a five foot tall
woman or something like that because
they have to do that because most of the
examples we would all kind of go I don't
know it just seems fine who really cares
you know
yeah I agree with that but I would think
like um like The Narrative of it could
be kind of if somehow uh
if an individual
um that was
um foreign
female and one in the male sports for
example uh wouldn't they themselves try
to be outraged by it or do you just
maybe they would I mean that would be
that would be super interesting like
imagine a situation where a trans man
competed in weightlifting in in the
men's weight lifting and one I don't
know what they would say they probably
would figure out a way to be outraged I
don't know they would say oh I don't
know where the performance enhancing
drugs or I don't know what they would
say it's an interesting question
yes uh something I've been looking into
recently for the past few years and
definitely taking notice to it with
Trump
um like saying no no mail and women's
sports in a sense that they only
highlight that issue in a lot of his
rallies as he just um exposes that all
the time and his women in men's sports
they seem to be fine with
exactly and I'm I'm curious to see how
this develops over time and thank you
for your input on this it's really
helped me out a little bit more Ray it's
been a pleasure Ray from North Carolina
great to speak to you we're going to
take a very quick break but we're going
right back to Discord and we're going to
hear from more people in a moment so
don't go anywhere